I had to have my dog neutered right I
had a sheepdog when he was 12 years old
the vet said you should have him
neutered it'll cause him more trouble as
he gets older man it's just not easy for
a man to commit another male neutered
you know it's like I said trim his nails
and work your way up slowly
you know Garry Shandling of course when
the influential comedian died two years
ago today he was remembered as both a
top stand-up comic and the creator of
two of the most innovative sitcoms in
television history
it's Garry Shandling show and the Larry
Sanders Show and now Shandling's the
subject of the Zen diaries of Garry
Shandling it's a new documentary by
fellow comedian and film director Judd
Apatow jimmy wax has the story
Jamie good morning good morning Reena
judd apatow had amazing access to his
hugely successful but in some ways
insecure subject he was allowed to
review Shandling's personal journals
letters recordings and videos I sat down
with his fellow performers Dave Coulier
penny Johnson Gerald and SNL alum Kevin
Nealon who are all featured in the film
and who called Garry Shandling a friend
and inspiration I once made love for an
hour and five minutes all right which
well it was on the day you push the
clocks ahead but I don't why does this
man such a mentor to so many people a
guy who's so complicated and so
uncertain of his own choices why did he
influence so many other people's choices
because he was doing what we aspired to
do and he was doing it well his
craftsmanship of his jokes were amazing
and his performance is great and we
wanted to be like him
Garry would meet you on the level that
you are and challenge you to be better
than that I don't talk about my hair
anymore because I've matured and and
realized now that looks aren't important
it's what kind of hair you have inside
and everything gary created was crafted
with a certain tip of the hat towards
his own vulnerability I'm on my way to
Hawaii that vulnerability is seen
throughout a Patel's documentary the Zen
diaries of Garry Shandling we're gonna
Gary was always very difficult because
he was as brilliant as anybody's ever
been in comedy writing it would be like
trying to paint with Picasso and
Picasso's like why are you using read
Apatow is admiration came early how
would you describe the type of humor
that you do it oh man he was just 16
when he scored an interview with the
comedian for his high school radio
station I was obsessed with comedy and
hunting down all my heroes to get to
meet them and Gary was somebody that I
really looked up to even then the two
were close friends up until Shandling's
death in 2016 which came as a terrible
surprise to everyone who knew him my
wife came up the stairs and shocked and
I heard her saying yelling oh no oh no
and I didn't know who died she told me
5b was a shock shock he was complex at
times neurotic persnickety and
high-maintenance a perfectionist with
the highest standards and he could be a
handful kneeling was one of Shanley's
close friends asked to speak at the
comedian's memorial I think the fact
that he spelled his name with two R's
was a warning that he was going to be
complicated Apatow got the idea for the
documentary after creating material for
the service material that went beyond
the comedy Shandling was known for it's
odd that Prince just died because Gary
and Prince were very similar
there really were no differences when
you really get down to it even though he
struggled that his real focus was on
being a better person being a more
loving person being there for other
people and it moved people deeply in a
way I had never seen before and I
thought there was probably a way to to
make a documentary that that could
inspire people and move people in the
same way
none of these journals are the same and
it reflects from the time I was 25 till
now after his death Apatow
learned about the stacks of journals
Shandling Left Behind dating back to
1977 like this is him working on his
resume did it seem overwhelming to try
and and capture the spirit of this guy I
wasn't overwhelmed in the beginning it
was very hard to just listen to him just
as a friend it's hard to watch
everything and dive deep into his head
he wrote in one entry your strength now
is to move on to live moment to moment
and he ended with that is discipline it
will require strength the material
helped provide a rare glimpse into a
public figures private reality including
how major incidents shaped his life
influenced his creativity and even
affected his ability to trust and the
first one that really stands out is the
death of his brother from cystic
fibrosis when he was a small child how
much did the death of Barry Shandling
affect Garry Shandling for me it was
just so interesting thinking I never
knew this about Gary but it's also like
Gary's joke
when he says his friends tell him that
he has intimacy problems but they don't
know me yeah only when I was going
through everything for the documentary
did I realize that this seemed to be one
of the most important moments of his
life this is a good night for a young
comedians first appearance on network
television another important moment in
his life was his debut on the ultimate
stage The Tonight Show
babies crawling around on the carpet
this baby loads up his diaper you know
and I'm sitting there you know and the
mother comes over and says isn't that
adorable
Brandon made a gift for daddy now I'm
figuring this guy's got to be real easy
to shop for on father comedian Bob Saget
was backstage that night and described
Shandling's reaction in the documentary
and he came over and he fell into my
arms and he was crying and he said I
don't know what to do now I said you're
so you were magnet so unbelievable he
said I don't know what to do cuz this is
all I ever wanted to do and I just did
it
Shandling spent his life trying to
master his craft but in fact the secret
to his success may have been something
you can't acquire but something you peel
away what's the most important thing
Gary Shandling left the entertainment
industry comedy the world I think Gary
taught us all and least with us all the
freedom to be naked in the ability to be
able to laugh at yourself I look at Gary
as an innovator not only with his
stand-up but what he did for for
television I'm seeing my mother sleep
before and she doesn't sleep like this
nobody does I know you've never met my
mother before but you really caught her
on a bad day he taught me that real
comedy comes from truth being honest I
think basically what he was trying to
say and all of us work is that people
should love each other and take care of
each other and be kind and when they
aren't it's funny I have a hospital bed
you know I have a mirror over my bed and
on it it says objects are larger than
they appear
[Music]
that's one of my favorite lines of his
for sure the two-part documentary
premieres on HBO this Monday and Tuesday
and it's well worth watching it's it's
four plus hours
I have screened it you know they send us
these screeners for research I at all
have watched it three times really it's
it's incredibly moving
yeah it's very human and just like his
comedy he's really trying to work
through the the condition of being human
it's fascinating that he kept those
journals for so long and so interesting
to hear an artist talking to himself yes
and it's so touching just to see how
moved these folks were that were close
to him just two years after his death
that they really are just moved by what
he's done for them and the impact they
had on their careers when we were
together in that room we laughed a lot
but there was such a huge sense of loss
it was really palpable it really is
well Garry Shandling had a very thriving
career in the spotlight and to Jamie for
joining us